je t'ai récemment dans l'Allier et la
présidente des maires de l'Allier qui
traînent très dynamique très concrète
qui qui a su
réunir au-delà des clivages partisans
dans un département qui était très
marqué
me disait que le nombre il me montrait
statistique à l'appui que le nombre de
démission d'élus municipaux maires
adjoint conseiller municipaux était un
en deux ans de 2020 à 2022 ils ont fait
deux fois plus que sur les six années
précédentes donc ça fait ça fait 6 fois
plus
donc et je pense qu'une des causes
majeure est la difficulté à exécuter
des décisions de tous les tous les
projets de mandats ne sont pas
fantaisistes beaucoup de mères sont des
gens très immense majorité c'est des
gens très très concrets très
pragmatiques il y a parfois des gens qui
promettent n'importe quoi mais c'est
assez rare au plan municipal donc les
projets de mandat sur lesquels on est
élu ils sont plutôt raisonnables ils
tiennent compte des contraintes de la
commande publique de la difficulté
décisionnelle or on se rend compte que
même en en tenant compte même en mettant
des filets de sécurité financier
juridique et temporelle on a de plus en
plus de mal à exécuter nos projets de
mandats donc ça alimente la spirale
infernale de la défiance les citoyens
mais j'ai lu pile il devait refaire la
place machin ou la fontaine trucmuche ou
créer une Maison des Jeunes et puis
c'est toujours pas sorti de terre le
meurtre allait comme un dingue il est de
bonne foi son administration aussi
donc c'est une question et vous avez
raison de la mettre au coeur de vos
travaux fondamental